[Música]
od es el puerto más importante educan ya
pero también es una de las ciudades más
representativas por su historia y su
cultura los lazos de odessa con rusia se
remontan a su fundación pero por estos
días así creen se crecen los temores
ante una posible ataque las tropas rusas
de esa ciudad que podría darse por
tierra también por mar nuestro primer
invitado al día es que nadie turca no
fue el ex alcalde de odessa nuestra
enviada especial catalina comenzaba en
el discutió con él sobre los vínculos de
rusia sobre la tensa situación en el
terreno
estamos con el alcalde de la ciudad de
oberá finavia y trujano muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana sabemos que son tiempos bastante
ocupados y quiero empezar preguntándole
cuál es la situación de la ciudad danesa
hoy su inicio villa pues está hoy
relativamente pacífica gracias a dios
aún no nos han atacado ni bombardeado
por lo que la situación se mantiene
tranquila pero tensa no perdón durante
varios días
d era inminente que pasó porque las
cosas se relajaron
no puedo responder completamente a esta
pregunta sé que los planes para atacar y
capturarlo de sant existen por lo tanto
todos los días surgen varias
informaciones sobre el posible
desembarco que marque el inicio de la
ofensiva sobre ves si no se ha dado
hasta ahora es porque hay feroces
batallas cerca de mi cola y de dos meses
que se encuentran en el camino de las
columnas enemigas que se están moviendo
hoy hacia dónde estás
creo que lo más probable es que estén
esperando hasta que se aproximen las
fuerzas terrestres para luego acercar
los barcos del mar y
el jinete sacar hombres mueran adhesión
de cierta manera ha tenido tiempo más
que otras ciudades para prepararse y
para alistarse para uno
como se está preparando en la ciudad
como y cómo es la moral de la ciudad en
este momento el distrito en la gresca
varona nica huelva hoy diciendo que la
persona si de hecho la heroica defensa
de miguel ayrton voz de sense que y
gerson le dio de esa ese precioso tiempo
para prepararse no vamos bueno series y
ponte todos monicelli alegría más de 9
bucle plenos words forlín wake up there
no gastamos tiempo en vano certificamos
nuestra ciudad construimos barricadas
pusimos erizos antitanque formamos
unidades de defensa territorial y
batallones de voluntarios y cada día
fortalecemos más nuestra situación
voleibol en triple-a word
[Música]
respuesta de la población de odessa para
unirse a las defensas territoriales a la
defensa de la ciudad entiendo que
muchísima más gente de la que podían
aceptar se unió a estas defensas este
editor territoriales
200 500 alcaldes cientos son muchos los
habitantes de odessa y de nuestra región
que quieren inscribirse y enrolarse en
las fuerzas de defensa territorial
batallones de voluntarios ellos mismos
organizan grupos para la autodefensa de
odessa
la unidad de los ucranianos y su
patriotismo ha llegado a su punto más
alto hoy todos se han unido contra la
guerra contra la agresión
el problema ahora es que no tenemos
capacidad de aceptar les a todos
problemas
suárez
se está creando nuevas alternativas
estaba buscando cómo traer más armas
para poder
involucrar más personas en esa defensa
de lo de eso porque al fin y al cabo
esta ciudad es estratégica para la moral
para la defensa de todo gran ya que son
muchos de ellos ni cabo a un cautivo de
ciertos jueces entre sueños no decimos
no a nadie todos los que quieren
participar en la defensa de ucrania y
odessa creamos listas de reserva para
las unidades por si en algún momento
fuera necesario como cielo de prensa de
cebolla sobre la decisión ha sido de 30
gran amor por lo menos increíble a todos
los que quieren registrarse dejan sus
datos se mantienen en contacto y cuando
hay necesidad les llamamos y vienen a
participar
es mayoritariamente rus
de hablar está muy relacionada por
muchas razones históricas culturales
[Música]
cuál ha sido el impacto
psicológico y moral para que sean los
rusos quienes están atacando atacando y
también amenazan con destruir las
muñecas de donde venimos con carne de
botón bruma noche hablamos de ello todo
el día y pensamos en ello todos los días
por la tarde por la noche o deza está en
estado de shock moral y humanamente
hasta el día de hoy aún no hemos
procesado que rusia está bombardeando
las ciudades ucranianas que hoy los
buques de guerra rusos están amenazando
que los aviones de combate rusos están
volando sobre odessa amenazándonos con
ataques aéreos así es que fijar a hacer
gracias al amor que te ayudarán pero que
muy cauto manía nacional ya que también
soy
estamos conmocionados
esto es un gran error político y un
crimen de guerra
pueblos que eran cercanos amables amigos
hoy han creado tanta división entre
nuestros pueblos
se dijo que esto era muy cercano a rusia
en lo personal esta invasión en esta
guerra creada por el presidente vladimir
putin como él ha afectado su posición
ahora en lo personal
en público
siempre me acusan de hecho probablemente
se deba a informaciones falsas que
aseguran que yo tenía ciudadanía y
pasaportes de rusos
demostramos que no era verdad de hecho
soy una persona nacida en la unión
soviética y como tantas otras personas
nacidas en la urss yo pensaba que
todavía estábamos en el espacio
postsoviético
para como
y mentales a diez experiencias que
quitan data en el primer parte de
nuestro dinero b dueña
tenemos la misma mentalidad compartimos
algunas fechas históricas por ejemplo la
victoria en la segunda guerra mundial la
religión es la fe también nos une así
que todo esto formó una huella en mi
orientación pero no estoy aquí para
excusar a odessa es una ciudad
internacional en génova producción no ya
gestiones con esto otro tercio produzca
un día centran sana le guardo todo el
servicio y querían darle a esa capital
cultural ustedes tienen tesoros como la
ópera como muchísimos patrimonios
históricos de la humanidad que están
haciendo para protegerlos
y hasta dónde están dispuestos a luchar
o parar la lucha para que están
destruidos
ya has visto las barricadas que hay por
la ciudad estamos listos para protegerla
y defenderlo lo único a lo que no
podemos hacer frente son los ataques con
misiles y los ataques aéreos por eso
pedimos cerrar el espacio aéreo sobre
ucrania esto nos permitirá proteger
nuestros monumentos arquitectónicos
incluido el famoso teatro de ópera
tractores la alcalde y para terminar
ustedes tienen el puerto más importante
de todas horario por aquí no solamente
salen la mayoría de exportaciones sino
que europa todo el trigo que más o menos
que consume y que se está haciendo para
el puerto y hay alternativas de
protección para que esa puerta de
ucrania hacia el mar no se cierren o
sea mientras continúe la guerra y haya
presencia de las fuerzas navales rusas
en el mar negro el comercio va a ser muy
peligroso y no todos querrán enviar
mercancías a través del puerto de odessa
quiero remarcar que el puerto de odessa
no es solo el puerto de la ciudad lo que
llamamos grano de esa incluye 7 puerto
cada uno con sus propios flujos de carga
esto provoca un daño muy grave en las
relaciones exteriores de ucrania ya que
estamos hablando de su acceso al mar y
de la posición de ucrania como potencia
marítima
todavía hay una última
ventanita para que no sea tan ciones a
usted cree que se puede salvar por
supuesto no lo dudo esa es una ciudad
heroica gente hermosa vi verdes nos
encanta el humor está en nuestro adn
pero cuando es necesario los habitantes
de odessa se vuelven muy poderosos
fuertes y devotos de su ciudad
muchísimas gracias